Before we get started,
we want to remind you
that Good Mythical Evening
is happening again on September 1st.
This the R-rated version
of Good Mythical Morning.
If you are an adult and you
feel like you're ready for it,
it could be a lot of fun.
If you're into that
type of thing, you know?
It gets a little explicit.
It gets a little off the rails,
goodmythicalevening.com.
It's exclusively on Moment House,
livestreaming ticketed event.
Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting
we're going on a verbal vacation.
Ah.
And to hear
you talk about it.
The way I said it last time.
Teasing it last week,
it sucked but you know what?
It's better to have a
good story than good time.
And you know,
as I've gone through all the
experiences that I have had
and then tried to figure how
I'm going to talk about them,
I have realized that it was all worth it
just for this moment you know?
Like whatever I went through
and however.
All right, don't put
too much pressure on yourself.
I'm just saying that
like, I just feel like,
I don't know how
entertaining it's gonna be
but I think it's gonna be very cathartic
for me just to get it all out there.
Oh, but I want to give a
quick interjection, reminder.
Good Mythical Evening, the second one
is happening September 1st.
Yes.
Exclusively on Moment House.
It's a live ticketed event,
R rated version of GMM.
If you're an adult, grab yourself a ticket
at goodmythicalevening.com a'ight?
Again man, whenever
something goes sideways,
it's great to have a podcast
where you know it's like,
well now I know what I can talk about.
I tried to keep that
in mind the whole time
and I do.
You did?
I do think it helps.
That's good.
It's good to not be in the moment
but to be kind of like
in performance mode.
And I'll just go ahead and
get started, why not right?
Yeah.
I mean but I will say
last night, Lily asked me,
I guess she was prompted by observing me.
She was just watching you?
Christy and I were in bed
and she comes up.
That's creepy.
She comes upstairs.
She's got a job.
I heard about it.
She's got a summer job.
She's a barista.
So she comes home, she's
got her uniform on.
I'm so proud of her.
She comes in the room,
we're asking her about
everything and then like,
I was totally tucked into
bed and then she's like,
"Is that how you sleep dad?"
I'm glad that she's
turning out to be normal.
And I'm like.
I'm just thankful for that.
I'm like, "Yeah."
And I was like, "You
just use that pillow?"
I was like,
"You haven't heard about
my physical therapy pillow?
"Yes, this is the only,
"this little log is the only thing I use."
And so you like,
and she's like, "So you sleep like this?"
And it was like a smushed
frog on a highway,
like on its back.
And I was like, "Yeah."
She was like, "Why are you so weird?"
Yeah, Lily's got her head on straight.
And I'm like, "For your
entertainment Lily."
She was like, "Really?"
I was like, "Yeah yeah,
I live to entertain you."
I gotta hang out with Lily
for reasons that we'll
get into in a little bit.
Right.
Me and Jessie and Lily and her friend
actually got to go to a concert together.
Yeah, I'm not happy about it.
And I was.
I'm okay, I'm happy for you.
Lily is, she's got her head on straight.
She understands that her dad is weird.
The thing that is important
is if you have a weird dad.
Yeah.
You can get lost in the weirdness.
Uh-huh.
And lose perspective.
Or you can understand the weirdness
and just maintain some groundedness
and I think that's what she's done
so I'm proud of her.
She loves me for it.
You know?
She's gonna keep me
around for a long time.
Okay, I'll get started
'cause there's multiple steps to this.
It wasn't just one trip to one place.
There was multiple things that happened.
So we were planning on
going to North Carolina
as the main part of this vacation.
It was like go back to
North Carolina, see family.
Also Jessie is working on this
vacation place slash Airbnb.
We don't know exactly what it's gonna be.
The vacation home that we've bought there.
She's doing her design thing
on it and so we're like,
"Okay, we're gonna make
the most of the time there
"and stay near the cabin."
But we've got a little bit of
time in this two-week window
where we can also just do
a little family vacation.
Let's just do something simple
like drive to Santa Barbara,
beautiful place that's only
like 90 minutes away from us.
And it would just be me and Shepherd,
I mean me and Jessie and Shepherd.
I don't know who put Shepherd second.
Jessie and I and then our son Shepherd
and Locke may or may not show up
because he's hanging out with his friend
and they're doing things and not,
you know I don't know
exactly how it's gonna go.
So Jessie's been very
busy, I've been very busy.
So we did not do as
much of, let's just say,
vetting and research on
this particular Airbnb
that we were gonna stay at.
All we knew is that it was
an incredible location,
like right on the beach.
One of those situations
where you've got waves
literally at high tide
crashing into the structure
that you are sleeping in at night.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean you can't go wrong with that
unless the house falls into the ocean.
But that's not my problem,
unless I'm in the house at the time.
Sounds like you could be.
It's a wonderful thing about renting.
Of course the whole time I
was there I was thinking,
"Man, what would it be
like to own this place?
"I'd be constantly worried about
it falling into the ocean."
Right.
So all right, there's a
couple of things that lead up
to the vacation where I,
we had some pictures, some old pictures
that we were getting down
from storage to go through
and scan some for a James
and the Shame related thing
that we're doing.
Now it turns out
we're not gonna use any
of these particular photos
at this point.
You'll understand weeks from
now what I'm talking about.
So I'm carrying big things.
Not just this big thing of pictures
and getting all this crap down
but I'm also like getting the suitcases
and carrying them down the stairs.
I carried Jessie's suitcase.
Whenever I do this kind of
thing, often before a vacation,
I end up unintentionally
stressing out my lower back.
I always thought that I
was hurting my lower back
before I went on vacation
because it was a transition
and I was trying to relax
and that may be part of it
but I think it's because
I'm just carrying a lot of
right before you go on vacation.
So when we arrive at the
place, I'm kind of like,
I'm already in a little bit
of a bad mood 'cause I'm like,
"Man, my back is hurting me
"and I know it's gonna take 48 hours
"before I can paddleboard
"which is the thing I'm excited about."
Is just being right there on the beach
and being able to go out there
and catch some waves man.
You know what I'm saying?
Or at least just paddle
around like an old guy.
Sure.
But we arrive at the Airbnb and we walk in
and the first thing that we all notice,
not just the tall guy is
that the ceilings are,
low.
Now I will say in the Airbnb
description it did say,
this is like the base.
It's the bottom floor of a two-unit thing
and it's an old place
and the ceilings are a
little bit low in places.
There's some beams or something.
We didn't read it closely enough.
Okay.
But what I'm saying
is that if you are over 5'9.
Wow.
You would have had to duck
to miss these beams that are
all throughout the house.
Also the bathroom seemed
like it was made for Hobbits
and all this was taken
with wide angle lenses
on the Airbnb listing.
So we had really no idea it
was as extreme as it was.
But then I just started walking around.
They didn't have a Rhett stick
for reference?
No.
Which they have here in the GMM studio.
A 6'7 tall stick.
Right.
That stands in for you.
We need to ship the
Rhett stick ahead of time
and have somebody go around
and take pictures with it.
But Jessie begins taking
pictures of me and you know,
my wife is a bit of a,
she knows what she's
doing on the social media.
If you follow her, you know this.
So she was like, "I've gotta
make this into a post."
She was like, "Let me just
take some pictures of you."
And the only thing she
said in her tweet was,
"Just arrived at our Airbnb."
With three or four pictures
of me standing there
with my head completely gone because.
Like behind a beam?
Behind a beam.
And I don't know how many
hundreds of thousands of likes
or tweet it has at this point
but it is the most viral
tweet I've ever been
in personal proximity to.
I mean I've been on Twitter since,
I don't know, well over a decade.
We have a lot of professional tweets.
And I am a relatively
internet famous person.
Never had a viral tweet.
My wife just farts one out.
Of course as I told her, I was in it.
Of course you couldn't see my face.
I mean your bottom half.
She did not tag me.
So anyway, while she got
a viral tweet out of it
which was pretty awesome.
We immediately began to,
I had taken all this
stuff down these stairs.
Like you had to come downstairs
to get to the unit where
you could go in the side
and then go around and get in there.
And I'm settled in.
And she's mad, she's happy about the tweet
but she's mad about the situation.
And she says,
"I just think we should,
"we should just go somewhere else.
"You're not gonna be
able to enjoy yourself,
"you're gonna be ducking
around this thing."
Oh it's only one bathroom.
This is something that was in the listing
that we just didn't really
look at and it's technically,
it's got four bunk beds that are outside
in the living room area kind of?
So Shepherd was gonna be
sleeping in this bunk bed
that's kind of out in the open
and then sharing a bathroom with us.
And 13-year-old needs privacy
if you know what I mean?
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
And so you could kind of tell
that he's a little bit antsy
and then Jessie's like,
"We'll just try to find a hotel.
"We can get our money back for the."
And I'm like, "We've already
moved all our stuff in.
"I'm the tall one.
"I'm the one who should be
complaining and I'm not.
"Let's just try to enjoy ourselves."
Not a great way to start a vacation.
Yeah.
Yelling at each other
about how you need to
try to enjoy yourself.
And she couldn't think of other ways
to continue to make more viral tweets.
It's kind of like.
You go into that, you
dig that well one time.
You know what I'm saying?
Yep.
So, but I was like,
there's a lot to love about this.
The location is beautiful,
there's a freaking hot tub
on the deck out there
overlooking the beach.
There you go.
And I immediately
got into it.
There you go.
By myself, no one got in there with me.
No low beams over it?
Well.
You're seated.
But I will say the deck from
the upper part is over you.
So there's no sun.
That was another thing that wasn't great.
It would've been nice to be on the top.
Wow, you're in.
You guys are you know,
if you care this much,
you kind of need to read the description.
It sounds like.
Lesson learned.
Everything you're complaining
about you immediately say,
"It was in the description."
I'm just gonna point that out.
Well it wasn't, you know how,
they're not gonna.
That's the art to Airbnb.
They make it all positive.
They make the negative positive.
You've gotta interpret everything
as a worst case scenario.
I mean.
If they mention it
in any way and it can be
interpreted as a negative,
then the reality is, it's very negative.
You have to be committed
to reading all the reviews.
And here's the thing
I look for in reviews.
I made a mistake about that,
there was only two reviews.
Yeah, two reviews.
One of the things I've learned to look for
in Airbnb reviews is
somebody, at least one person
saying something good about the mattresses
'cause that's a big thing for me.
It's like, if you don't have
a good mattress that can suck.
Of course I bring
my own pillow.
And a square pillow right?
No I bring my own pillow.
It's small enough for me to pack.
All right, well.
You know that.
I'm happy for you.
That's a little tip.
The bed was okay.
Okay.
The bed wasn't bad.
But anyway, so things
were slightly charged
you might say.
A couple of days in, Shepherd is already,
he's kind of bored
because he can't get into a personal space
you know what I mean?
And I was like, yeah I hate that for him
'cause he likes to get on and you know.
Hide.
Talk to his boys
and play games and stuff.
So he's getting a little bit amped up.
The TV, we wanted to,
the first night we wanted
because we were all caught up.
We wanted to watch the
"Stranger Things" finale
but the TV remote didn't work.
Oh, you're doing that thing
where you're trying to find
a button on the back of the
television just to turn it on?
And also.
Can I use my phone for this?
We couldn't connect to
the Sonos sound system.
So it's like, there was a lot of things
that were kind of falling
apart and making it stressful
and making it difficult to enjoy.
Now these are very.
Meanwhile remember.
Privileged problems.
I was in Hawaii.
Remember how good of a time
I had?
You were having
a great time.
Best vacation ever.
Potentially.
Now so we have some good experiences,
had a few good meals.
I did eventually get out on the water.
But then I'd say four nights,
it's like a five night
thing to get kind of,
before we went to North Carolina.
Fourth night I'm like,
"Jessie, we have to go
through these pictures."
You brought the pictures.
So I said, "I have a system in mind
"for how I'd like to go."
Again, what I'm thinking
when I approach this
is we have a bunch of
pictures from the past
before we had digital cameras.
So this is lots of, from
college, from after college,
from early marriage and I'm like,
"I want to be able to enjoy these photos
"and look through them.
"So my idea is if we scan the
ones that we want to scan."
Mm-hmm.
Then we can enjoy them.
Jessie's expectation that she
brought to this process was.
Oh.
"We're gonna enjoy this right now.
"Why can't we just we enjoy it right now?
"We're looking at these pictures.
"Let's enjoy it right now."
Yeah.
And,
we clashed.
Oh.
Again, tensions already high
but we clashed in this situation
and it ended up getting.
We got into a pretty big argument about it
because I was unrelenting
and she was unrelenting
'cause I was like.
Yeah.
"I'm gonna keep doing my system
"because I want to get done with this.
"I don't want to do this tomorrow night."
You're making a scan pile.
And she's making a memory.
Basically, yeah.
I want to make the memory in
the future and she's like,
"Oh look at us when this so and so."
So it's a romantic opportunity.
I'm like, "Yeah but I, that's later."
That's later.
Right now is the system.
Yeah.
And let me also add two other factors
that are going into the
stress level being high.
As you know,
we rarely take an actual vacation.
So I'm out on vacation
but I'm taking meetings.
I'm joining meetings,
I'm doing Zoom meetings.
I'm doing emails.
Yeah.
We're continuing
to be bosses to some degree.
For the meetings that we couldn't miss.
Yeah.
There's some,
as always, it ebbs and flows
but we were kind of in a season,
that week especially where it's just like,
some uncertainty about
some things developing,
projects and stuff that
are just kind of like,
you can't get out of your mind.
Lurking.
So unresolved things.
Yep.
That were kind of stressing
me out and then of course,
I'm trying to get ready to announce this
James and the Shame project and also I,
doing a lot of it on my own
getting ready for this launch
and doing a lot of the technical back end
and even design of some of this stuff
and so.
Yeah.
There's just a lot right?
So it's like tensions are high
and everything is adding to the tension.
So we'd kind of snapped
and went to bed angry.
Oh.
Okay?
We wake up in the morning and I'm like,
"Hey, let's take a walk on the beach."
Okay.
"Let's try
"to hit the reset button."
Clean slate.
We are in a beautiful location,
especially if we're not in the house.
It's a good idea.
If we get outside, we
forget about the low beams.
You know, we forget
about the one bathroom.
We forget about our son.
I hope this worked.
It didn't.
We get out on the beach, beautiful.
We're walking and then we begin talking
and we kind of pick up
right where we left off.
About the pictures?
I don't know how it started but I,
I thought this is an opportunity
to clear this stuff up
and I tried to kind of come into
the conversation with somewhat.
I was like,
"I feel like we brought
different expectations
"into this process."
But we didn't really
get to talk about that
because we kind of just ended up restating
exactly what our positions
were the night before
and at that point.
Nobody budged.
We went from a couple walking on the beach
to just two people walking
on the beach in a line.
Oh.
In a line that grew.
She was in front I bet?
She was in front.
Yeah yeah yeah.
And at one point I would just say.
Her legs must've been moving fast
to stay in front of you.
We were just two people on a beach
or a man following a woman on a beach.
Not sure what's gonna happen there.
But she was a good 50 yards
is where we kind of settled you know?
It was just.
Oh wow.
Two people walking on
the beach and I was like,
"Eventually we're gonna get to a place
"where we can't go any further
"'cause that's what happens
on California beaches."
And it's on her to turn around.
She's gotta turn around
at some point so she does.
At which point we meet and
then we start walking together
and then it was a good
opportunity to have that space.
We began talking and I'm a calm demeanor
and we actually got to.
At least she didn't
turn around and.
Slap me?
You were like 50 yards, you see her.
She's picking up speed, picking up speed.
And just runs past me.
She just like, tackles you.
Oh well, I'm a big man.
So we ended up getting to a good place
and talking about how
when we collaborate on things like that
we have to state what our
expectations and intentions are
and if we are bringing
very different expectations
and intentions to something,
then we need to make some adjustments.
It was really the, everything
accumulating you know?
As with most big fights
that are about nothing,
it's really everything else.
Which you've outlined.
True.
You know?
But this was also the day
that we were going to go whale watching.
Whale watching?
And I'm gonna tell you all about -
Is it the right time of year for that?
Oh it's the right time buddy,
let me tell you how right it is.
I'm gonna tell you all
about whale watching,
how that may be the thing
that completely redeemed the
entire vacation in a second.
But first, don't you have a podcast?
Yeah I'm doing it man,
I'm just listening to you.
No but you have another podcast.
I have another one.
I've got a couple.
Yeah.
I've got like three or four in the works.
No I just got, I don't
want any more podcasts.
"Dispatches From Myrtle
Beach" is going good.
If you haven't checked
it out, check it out.
I know people are asking
for a video version,
the time's not right for that.
But we will keep it in mind.
So if you'll only listen if you can watch,
I would just ask for
you to give it a shot.
Listen, just go.
You know I think.
Over there to wherever
you get your podcasts
and just listen for 30 minutes.
Listen to episode one.
If you don't like that,
you won't like any of the other ones but.
I think it's one of the funniest things
that Mythical has ever made.
I think you gonna like it.
Thank you.
And I end up finding myself.
I can't take credit for it.
It's mostly your dad.
Yeah.
So I end up, even,
the other night when we
were at a party at my house
and you were there.
I ended up just playing,
I just held out my phone
and played a clip from
Mythical Pods for everybody.
Because I just want people.
I'm just like, you have to understand.
Right.
You gotta understand
what's going on here.
You need to check this out.
Yeah.
This is entertainment, pure entertainment.
So go listen to it.
There's a lot of levels to it.
There's, I feel like it's,
people describe it as raunchy at times.
People describe it as wholesome
and usually they describe
those things at the same time.
Where else can you get that?
Yeah, right.
Well there's a certain
part of Hallmark stores.
Oh really?
Yeah, right.
Yeah that's kind of what
"Dispatches From Myrtle Beach" is.
Wherever you get your podcast
all right, listen to it.
Okay, whale watching.
Okay so we had set this up ahead of time.
We knew that we were supposed to.
It's on, thankfully I have
good people in my life
like Cara in this situation
who put this on my calendar
and tell me where I need to be
and when I need to be there.
10 a.m..
'Cause you get on a boat.
It's what it said and so I'm like,
"Well 10 a.m. is probably
when you're supposed to arrive
"and they start telling you
what you need to be ready for
"or whatever."
Wrong, we go through the harbor gate there
in the Santa Barbara Harbor at 9:59.
Ope.
And you have to get a ticket
and there's a woman at the gate.
And I didn't know where
I was supposed to go.
So I was just like,
"We're going whale watching."
She's like, "Oh well you better hurry
"because they leave at 10 o'clock sharp."
Oh.
So at that point I'm like,
"Oh crap."
We go, first of all, all the
tensions that had been built.
Are back.
And we're trying to find a
parking space in this giant lot
and I'm supposed to be on
this far end of the thing
to get on the boat and that was when
I hit the steering wheel and said,
"I hate this vacation!"
Wow.
Yep.
So my.
Definitely the
vacation's fault.
Yep, my wife and my son.
Thankfully only one of my
children was with me at the time
will forever remember that I'm sure.
So I said, "I'm gonna drop you guys off.
"You run to the boat,
you tell them I'm parking
"and tell them to wait."
So drop Shepherd and Jessie off.
They're running towards the boat.
I'm trying to find, I can't
find a spot in the lot
that I'm at next to the boat.
So I have to go out into another lot.
I park, I'm in flip flops y'all.
Jessie calls me, she says,
"The captain said you need to run."
The captain is now giving me messages.
Yeah.
"You tell the captain, I'm in flip flops."
Well I listened to the
captain and first of all,
have you just noticed
that as you get older
and then you have to run for
a reason and then you're like,
"Damn, running ain't easy."
Yeah you gotta.
Like jogging okay.
Six minute stretch beforehand at least.
Sprinting?
Sprinting in good running
shoes would be difficult.
Yeah.
For more than a couple,
like 10 to 20 yards.
But running 300 yards in flip flops,
I was making so much noise.
Flippity floppity .
It was like .
People probably thought there
was fireworks going off.
Pre-fourth of July.
I ended up making it.
Literally, not the captain but the,
one of the crew was like,
"Well all right, you're lucky."
Basically as I go up the little stairs
that they had set there
and he immediately removes
them as I get on the boat.
Was everybody on the boat looking at you?
Yeah, I made quite an entrance.
They heard me coming from
at least 200 yards away.
What is that, that's a tall
man running in flip flops.
So the first thing I noticed
as we settle in is that
everyone else has a lot more clothes on.
Nobody else is wearing
flip flops and shorts.
They're bundled up.
I'm talking pants and
like, those puffy jackets.
Oh gosh.
With hoods!
Yep.
And I'm like,
"Oh I should've read about this."
Now I do have a hoodie
on because I was like,
"Oh we're going out on a boat."
It was like 80 degrees in Santa Barbara
which is pretty warm for Santa Barbara.
I was like, "It can't be that
much cooler out on a boat."
It was.
Really?
The wind chill but also
just the sea air and.
Where did the boat go out to?
Channel Islands, so right
in between Santa Cruz
and whatever the other
island is right next to it.
Not Santa Cruz, Santa Cruz California.
Santa Cruz Island.
So off the coast of Santa Barbara
and off the coast of this
whole part of California
there is the Channel Islands
which technically Catalina
is part of that island chain,
it's just further south.
I'm gonna go scuba diving out there.
Yeah it's a beautiful place.
And there's an incredible
history about the islands
and a pretty sad history
about the native people
who were out there and how they were moved
to the shore to build the mission.
Huh.
When the Christians
showed up, they made them all leave
and go work on the mainland.
It was pretty horrible.
But it's a beautiful place
and the reason that it is.
Well it's a small price
for you to think you're
saving their souls.
Don't say you, but you mean them.
Yeah I know what you mean.
So the, the cool thing about this place
is that there's a lot of whale traffic.
I mean this is what whale
watching's all about.
You go to where the whales are.
On the inside of the islands
or on the outside of the island?
Especially in between the two islands.
Okay.
Something about
what's happening with the
wildlife at that place.
So influence, basically
makes it a feeding ground.
Now he said we should,
you know we'll probably
see some humpbacks.
I've never seen a whale,
never seen a whale.
For some reason I thought
it had to be winter,
January.
I don't think it could be July.
The season is, most of the year,
there's different whale types,
species that will be there
is what it looked like.
Oh wow.
But May
to sometime in the fall
is probably the best time.
Not only for the weather but also because
this time of year is when
the blue whales show up.
Largest animal on the planet.
Really, right there?
Largest animal
on the planet.
Now he said as we were going out.
He said, "We might see a blue whale.
"I will say it's not common.
"There's only 15,000 blue whales
"in the world at this point."
That's less than you would
see at a basketball game.
You know what I'm saying?
This is all.
I've never seen a whale
at a basketball game.
Exactly, all of the whales in the world,
blue whales in the world
wouldn't be able to fit
inside the you know,
the cryptodome just because
or whatever they call it.
Because they're bigger than people.
But just to give you an idea
of how many people.
Yeah yeah, it's sad.
So we, it took us awhile to get out there.
It's miles off of the coast
and you're going pretty fast.
Probably an hour.
On a big, more than an hour I think.
Maybe 90 minutes to get
out to the location.
One of the things that we
did see on the way out there
when we would venture out onto the deck
and freeze our asses off.
Because there was an inside area
where you could sit enclosed
and there was a snack bar,
pretty cool.
Dolphin pods, now we've seen dolphins,
you've seen dolphins,
we've surfed with dolphins
but when you get a couple
miles out from shore,
the dolphin pods are enormous.
I'm talking hundreds
of dolphins, hundreds,
it's overwhelming.
Beside the boat?
And then they see the boat
and they come swim with
it and they jump up.
They're smart.
They know so much that we
don't know that they know.
And they're like showing
off for us and stuff
and I'm like,
"This is pretty cool, okay.
"This horrible vacation's
getting a little bit better.
"What if we just see a whale?"
And at that point, we're
on our way out there
and the captain comes on
the loudspeaker and says,
"Okay we've spotted a whale,
"looks like we've got
a juvenile humpback."
They don't use terms like
port and stern and stuff
because we're all idiots.
And he just says, "On the
left, front side of the boat."
He just uses things that
everybody can understand.
It's still a ways off and I
was kind of amazed at how,
well I go out there
and I see this blowhole
from what felt like several hundred yards
and this guy somehow knows
that this is a juvenile humpback.
He's probably got binoculars but also.
Maybe a radar.
Sonar.
He's seen quite
a lot of whales.
And sure enough, we get
out there and I see,
and I made a commitment.
Hold on to your flip flops,
we're gonna run to the whale.
I made a commitment that was not going to
use my camera 'cause I was like,
"I wanna be in the moment."
And what's,
if people wanna see.
Right.
A video of a whale,
they can get one at
National Geographic maybe,
not Rhett you know what I mean?
Yeah.
So I'm like,
I wanna see this, I
wanna be in the moment.
So right now as you're talking about this
for the video version.
We're gonna cut to some
really amazing whale footage.
Hold your horses because
I can get to a video.
Hold your whales.
So we get up there and
we see this humpback
and it was a juvenile.
So I mean, I don't know,
this thing was probably 20 feet long.
It's a large animal.
It's the largest animal
I've been close to.
Next to the boat?
Like a dolphin would be?
No no no.
The whales don't come up,
maybe they do at times.
But these whales were not like,
"Hey we're gonna come show off for you."
They're more just like,
"I'm doing my thing,
I'm not scared of you."
So they get the boat, they
move the boat kind of close.
They turn the boat and they
move close to the whale
once you spot it.
And what happens is these whales come up
and they do their thing and
they stay near the surface
and they're doing their blowhole thing
and then they take a deep
dive and their tail comes up.
Woo, just like the commercials
and they go down and he's like,
"Okay, we're going to wait
seven to nine minutes now."
Huh.
Because once they
do the tail thing, they're going deep.
They don't always do
the tail thing but they,
if they do the tail
thing they're definitely.
Seven to nine minutes.
Seven minutes exactly later.
Wow.
The guy says, "Okay
it's been seven minutes.
"Keep an eye out."
And then as he's finishing his sentence,
here it comes again.
Because they're predictable,
they go down seven and nine minutes
and this one apparently was a sevener.
It comes up in the same spot?
No and he's like,
"Oh it's on the right side of the boat."
And so everybody goes to
the right side of the boat
and then we see it do its thing.
So we saw two humpbacks,
we ended up seeing a
mother and a juvenile.
It's really cool.
Huh.
Then he says,
"All right, we're gonna keep going
"because we need to get to the
area between the two islands
"which is where if we're
gonna see a blue whale,
"this is where we would see it."
So we start getting close to this spot
and the guy comes on the
loudspeaker and he's like,
"Okay well we've seen a
whale that's pretty far off.
"We're not exactly sure
what species it is.
"We're gonna keep moving.
"Just keep your eyes out on
"the left front side of the boat."
So we start going and then we get to,
again kind of like from 100 yards away
you see this thing come up
and you see this blowhole and he says,
"It's a juvenile blue whale."
What?
And I'm like, "Oh brother.
"We're seeing a blue whale."
We get up close to it, bump bump.
It's doing the same thing
that the humpback's doing.
Like coming up, blowing, breathing,
and then he says, before
this happens he says
now it's really, first of all he says.
You can kind of, he's got
some energy in his voice
'cause this is a big moment for him.
And he's like,
"We don't always see blue whales."
He's trying to let these people,
just us normies on the boat.
Yeah.
Understand what they're experiencing.
This is a once in a lifetime
opportunity and he says,
"This thing's gonna dive in a second.
"They usually don't do the."
He had a technical term for it.
They don't show the tail is what I say.
Show the tail in the same way every time.
It's less common for
blue whales to do that.
At that moment, the thing
comes up, shows its tail.
Yes.
And goes down.
And I'm just like, I'm
totally dadding out.
I'm grabbing Shepherd, I'm saying,
"It showed its tail son just for you."
What?
Yeah.
How long was this juvenile?
The juvenile, I would say 30 feet or so?
It's a big-ass thing right.
But then at that point he says,
"We've spotted an adult blue whale."
What, no?
But also when the thing
goes down he's like,
"Okay the blue will be down
from 10 to 12 minutes."
10 to 12.
Okay, so I got to see,
and I was pretty close,
relatively to this thing,
to the juvenile.
But then the adult comes
up and it's within,
50 yards, 40 yards of the boat.
Wow.
And at that point I was like,
"I've already seen a blue whale.
"I've seen a blue whale do the tail thing.
"I think I'm gonna film this
thing because now I can,
"now I can say I was
there and I enjoyed this."
And let me just show you right
now what I ended up getting.
This is a.
Of course we know
this isn't gonna be
National Geographic footage.
We all understand that.
But we're gonna let Rhett have his moment.
This is an adult.
You zooming in here.
Wow.
Look he's going,
he's going, he's going and also.
Got that tail.
Does the tail.
Whoa.
So slow.
Can you believe that?
I mean I know that again.
I don't have a
sense of scale.
National Geographic would have a,
you'd have a sense of scale.
They get to 90 feet long.
Okay?
I've been obsessed with these.
I don't think I've ever explained this my,
I was really into whales.
Especially as a kid, I had
whale stuffed animals and stuff
and any time I went to a
natural history museum,
there'd be, oh this is
the blue whale skeleton
that's hanging in this room or whatever.
Yeah.
I was just like,
"I can't believe that this thing exist."
Their heart is the size
of a Volkswagen Bus.
Pumps one time a minute.
Hah.
It sends that blood all over.
We're gonna wait 60 seconds.
For the heart to beat again.
And his heart's gonna
beat again.
And the dude on the
loudspeaker is just losing it.
He's like,
"You saw two blue whales,
they both did the tail thing."
Again, he's using the technical term.
I don't recall it.
The tip bucket
is at the starboard bow.
Yeah he did and I tipped well.
And like, I go.
I'm grabbing my wife and
my child and I'm just like,
"We just experienced this."
They don't seem as into it as me.
This is kind of a dad thing.
The largest living animal.
Yeah.
Yeah, just right there.
Just blowing for us.
We go back inside.
At this point the guy's like,
"All right now we need to turn
around and get back home."
We go back inside, we sit back down,
I look at my wife and my
child in the face and I said,
"I fucking love this vacation."
Turned it around for me.
Yeah you're.
It was that easy.
You're like a,
you're like a ship without a moor.
It's like you're, what's
it called you know?
A ship without an anchor.
You're just floundering
at sea.
I was in a
fragile state.
Sea of vacation man.
I was in a fragile state but.
We're gonna die, this
is the best day ever.
I mean seeing a blue whale
and seeing a blue whale do that thing
with its tail like that.
Redemption.
It made it all worth it.
It really, and as my vacation progresses
and things only get worse
as we're about to learn.
Okay.
I kept holding on
to that blue whale.
I stuck my hand.
I just put my whole body
right in its blowhole.
Up to my waist and just
grabbed on and said,
"This is the thing that
I am gonna hold onto."
Yeah.
So that was the next to last day.
We go home the next morning.
High on blue whale fumes.
Me and you have to take
a little trip together.
Yep that's when I, I got back from Hawaii
and then the very next
morning we have to meet up
and get on a plane.
Yeah Rhett and Link
going to Aspen, Colorado.
Never been to Aspen, I was
pretty excited about this.
This was a YouTube panel.
At the Aspen Ideas Fest.
We were invited to share our perspective.
It was livestreamed, you
might have caught it.
It was, it was quite a
little trip you know?
We got there that night,
we got up the next day.
We saw a little bit of Aspen,
stayed and did our panel.
Slept that night, got up next morning
and then flew our separate ways.
So you could continue your vacation
and I could go back home.
But yes, just,
I knew that Colorado
was a beautiful place,
I had been before.
Been to Vail but I had
been during the winter.
And never really been to a
ski town in the summer time
and I'd heard that oh,
"You gotta go to Aspen
in the summer time."
And you know this is.
You just have to see Aspen.
This is the ultimate rich place,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I mean the real estate
is just insultingly expensive and we were,
but it's so incredible.
It's just this incredible spot.
We walked around.
The airport is in this, is in the Valley.
Canyon.
But you drive around
the Valley and you're in Aspen proper
within like I don't know, seven minutes.
The thing that struck me was that,
I mean you've got these very
aggressively sloped mountains
on every side and of course,
you can see the ski slopes,
even though they're green.
Just right there and they come right down
to the base of the mountain
and it's the town of Aspen.
You could ski right into it.
And the town of Aspen
was established there
well before there was ski resorts there.
So it like,
and it's not just one road.
There's a grid of streets
with all types of long
established buildings.
Man that bank looks like it was there
in the frontier times.
Kind of a vibe.
Yeah it's pretty old.
So it's like,
it's a pretty expansive, old town
that still has this kind of vibe of like,
I've been here since I don't know.
Whenever it was established.
It's been there since it was established,
I can tell you that for sure.
One of the highlights for us
was we rented electric bikes.
We were told by Robert Kinsel,
the big man at YouTube
who was on our panel,
who we've gotten to know.
He was like, you need to ride
bikes down the Rio Grande,
which I couldn't have told
you that the Rio Grande.
Flew right through there.
Flew right through Aspen.
No blue whales.
So we did that and boy that,
I mean, I, there's a couple of
places I've been in the world
where I felt like I was in a fairytale.
You know what I mean?
Where it's just, this is
like this weirdly curated
part of the matrix
that's a little too nice.
Very pristine.
I mean right when we got on the bike path
we stopped and we're like,
"Oh look at those mansions
right there next to the creek
"that leads right here to the river."
And I looked at this,
it was this mansion built
on the side of this slope
and then right next to the house,
there was a waterfall.
Like a creek that became
a waterfall flowing like,
pretty vertically.
Right next to this
person's house.
Backyard waterfall.
I mean this is next level stuff.
And it had been curated by a landscaper
but it had not been
created by a landscaper.
Right, not at the house.
Imma build my house next
to this little waterfall.
Good gracious, it was.
I think.
It was so beautiful
that it was disturbing.
It was.
It was almost a little unsettling.
Yeah.
There's no grit.
Couldn't find any grit.
But we did go to,
several people had told us
that we needed to go to
a store called Kemo Sabe.
Which was this,
wearing the cowboy hat and the Stetson hat
is a thing that's kind of associated
with Western ski towns.
And this, we went, this place
makes these incredible hats.
I wasn't planning on
buying a hat, I didn't.
But they were like,
hats, boots, et cetera.
And they'll, if you're willing to pay,
like I don't know, it
might be a thousand dollars
or more for a hat.
Yeah these are nice hats.
Then they'll,
they'll put it on your
head and perfectly size it.
They'll steam it to fit your noggin.
No matter how wonky your head is.
Right.
They can put
a hat around it.
But we noticed when we walked
in that like five women
in their late 20s who
all had hats on sort of.
Very glammed up.
They kind of descend upon you
when you enter the store
and begin asking you,
"Do you need help?"
Following you around as you
go to the different things.
And I was very intrigued
with the knife section.
Yeah they had this total
glass case full of knives.
And there's a craftsman, I think for.
I ask her first.
I was like, what's the
deal with these knives?
Well and it's a craftsman from Georgia
who makes these knives.
She starts small, literally.
Like a small knife.
She brings it out and it's
got this cutting board
that you put this cheese
knife that's about this long,
about three inches long,
about three inches long
and she puts it on this little magnet.
To kind of make it suspend
itself above the cutting board.
All right.
And she's like,
"The handle of this one is
made from mammoth tooth."
Or something like that.
Yeah.
And it is $2900.
I was like.
Okay.
"You want me to cut some cheese
"with a $3000 knife."
And she kept going because apparently
we looked like we could
maybe get knives like this.
Yeah I mean.
I don't know
if it was the twinkle in our eye.
She moves on and let me
just, I'll cut to the chase.
Eventually she brings us to
a knife that was this long.
Yeah it's like a three
and a half foot knife.
That the handle for the knife
was the jaw of an extinct
fossilized cave bear.
And I'm talking about the huge cave bears.
Yeah.
That were
on the North American
Plains back in the day.
And this knife was $20,000?
Yes, yeah.
A knife.
I don't, did she let us touch it?
I don't remember actually.
No,
she didn't take that one out.
I think that by that point she saw,
the Buies Creek was really coming out
and we were thinking.
My golly, look.
Oh my goodness.
Look at the jaw
on that knife.
She's like, "I'm not
gonna get this one out
"for these fools."
They're obviously not gonna buy anything.
They're just gonna look
at stuff and leave.
We strolled out of there,
I mean you almost bought a wallet.
I thought well, a pair of gloves.
Oh yeah, pair of gloves.
Pair of leather gloves.
After being shown all of this.
So much leather in there.
I was like, oh there's a $65 pair
of really nice leather gloves.
We walked out of there with nothing.
We did.
Except this story.
But we had a great time in Aspen.
Now I was the,
you were gonna go back to Los Angeles
which I assume that
just happened, breezed.
You probably just got on a plane
and just went straight
to Los Angeles right?
No I had to fly through Denver.
Okay, but no complications?
No complications.
I on the other hand.
Red carpet man.
I continued with my troubles.
So I was supposed to fly
from Aspen to Denver and.
You had no troubles when you were with me.
You need to note that.
Denver to Raleigh.
Because you can't fly
from Aspen to Raleigh.
So we get on the runway in Aspen
and then the pilot comes
over the loudspeaker.
A lot of people talking
to me over loudspeakers
on this vacation now that
I'm thinking about it.
We've got a juvenile.
Yeah I was having trouble deciphering
between the pilot and the captain
which I guess is the
same person in some ways.
Yep.
The pilot comes on the
loudspeaker and says,
"We've got a problem, we're too heavy."
We're gonna remove the tallest guy
with the biggest hair.
Everyone start doing cardio right now.
He said basically there
was a mix-up and this plane
was a plane that was supposed to fly
to a different location
but there was a mix-up
because the night before,
a rich person in their private plane
went off of the edge of the runway
and they had to shut the airport down.
Because the Aspen airport
is notorious for accidents
'cause it's like this, the wind
and the short runway and all that stuff.
It's a small airport.
So he said,
"We can take off but we have to be
"at a certain weight to land
and I have three options.
"I can ask some of you to
leave which I don't want to do.
"I can have somebody come and take fuel
"directly out of the plane but
that takes a very long time."
For some reason.
"Or we can sit on the
runway and burn fuel."
This is a great time to just burn jet fuel
in the economy, you know what I'm saying?
This guy says burn it for the hell of it.
Oh God.
So he comes to that conclusion,
that that's what they're gonna do.
They're gonna sit
on the runway.
Did everybody vote?
Didn't appear to be a democracy.
You have three options.
Did not appear to be a democracy.
We sit on the runway for
30 minutes burning fuel
and then he has to add
an additional 15 minutes
to our route to Denver
which would've only been half an hour
and he was gonna make it 45 minutes
in order to get to the
right weight to land.
Because that's when
weight is really an issue
is when you're trying to land.
I mean just, he should just keep going up.
Keep gaining altitude, Icarus that.
But what ended up happening
was I missed my connection
because of all this.
At which point I ended up
getting on another plane
from Denver.
I was gonna go from Denver to
Houston, Houston to Raleigh.
While we're in the air going to Houston,
the pilot comes over
the intercom and says,
"We have a problem."
Houston has a problem.
"The Houston airport has been closed."
Closed?
"Due to weather.
"So we are diverting to Dallas."
Okay, so we land in Dallas.
We land in Dallas and the pilot says,
"Okay, we don't have enough
fuel to make it to Houston."
I know where you could've got some.
The first plane.
Yeah exactly right?
I could've brought it in my carryon.
So we had to wait for them to fuel,
all this stuff takes forever.
Now I am thankful that
we live in a country
which is pretty well regulated.
Damn.
So there are things like
lots of paperwork and
stuff that has to be done
to make sure that.
That's why people don't die
in commercial airline crashes
because of the regulations.
That's why you die in
private plane crashes a lot
if you're gonna die in a plane crash.
Because of all this,
all this logistics and
stuff they have to do.
But when you're really
wanting to get to Raleigh,
you're just like,
"Why can't you just fill the damn plane up
"and shut the door?"
I didn't say that.
Everyone remained remarkably
calm but I was like,
this day, this flight.
Trying to get to Raleigh
is becoming like a,
an analogy for the way
my life feels right now.
You know what I'm saying?
There was just a lot of, again,
I'm thinking a lot about
the album coming out too.
Because I was, I gotta announce the album,
the following week.
And I don't know how people
are gonna think about this
and they're gonna think
I'm dumb for doing this.
I'm thinking all these things
and I'm more stressed out
about that than I realize.
The business stuff that
we continue to talk about,
you know, there's just a lot of stress
and then I'm having this crazy day.
We end up flying, okay so yeah.
So we go from Dallas.
Means now we're gonna just fly to Houston.
So we fly from Dallas to Houston.
Okay.
And then we're gonna fly
from Houston and Raleigh
and the flight to Raleigh gets delayed.
But actually I'm thankful it got delayed
because I may not have made
it if it didn't get delayed.
So anyway I woke up at 5:30 a.m. that day.
Was on four different planes
and my wife picked me up
from the airport in Raleigh
at like midnight.
Wow.
So it was a long day.
Very happy to see my wife.
And you know when you're really happy
to see your wife and you're
going to a hotel room,
just the two of you.
You know what that leads to.
Oh yeah.
Missionary sex.
Okay.
Shout out to Trevor
on that one.
Yeah.
From the Smosh Funeral if you don't know.
And one of the things that,
and you'll understand why I'm
explaining this in detail.
One of the things that happens
when you've having missionary sex.
Oh god.
Is your faces.
Even though I'm much taller than my wife,
I do have a way of getting my face
close to her face during missionary sex.
Okay, okay.
And I was able to do that.
It takes a little flexibility.
And some arching of the back
but I was able to do that
and you know, we really
had a great reunion.
The reason I'm giving you these details
is because I did not know at
the time but my wife had COVID.
Oh.
Now she told me.
Did that missionary evangelize the COVID?
Oh she shared it with me all right.
She had told me that
she had a sore throat.
Now my wife has told me
she's had a sore throat
a hundred times over the
past couple of years.
Yeah.
And every time
she thinks she has COVID
and every time she hasn't.
You got to North Carolina, allergies man.
Whatever, like I've never
seen a positive COVID test.
Allergies hate COVID boy.
They're really getting a bad rep
with all this COVID.
Yeah.
So, but she wakes up
next day and feels worse.
Ends up taking a test, it's positive.
I'm like, dang it.
We had missionary sex,
we slept in the same bed.
So I'm basically like,
man I've totally been exposed
because you are really, really infectious
in the early stages of COVID especially.
Right before symptoms hit
and as symptoms are hitting.
At least with these latest varieties
is what I was gonna say.
What is the term?
I still have COVID brain.
Strains.
Because I got it.
Strains?
Isn't it?
Variants.
Yeah.
We're forgetting very simple words
which I'll talk about in a second.
But I'm like, I'm supposed to play golf
with my brother and my
dad the next day okay?
And this was a special golf
trip for a number of reasons.
Mainly because we were gonna play
Keith Hill's Country Club
which is the country
club I grew up next to.
Yeah.
My neighborhood
was outside the gate.
I didn't grow up in a country club.
Old stomping ground.
I could walk to the course.
You act like it.
The course, there's an original 18 holes
that is so weird how I played that course
so many times growing up
that it's so imprinted in my mind.
Unlike any other physical
space that large,
where multiple times throughout my life,
a lot of times when I'm
having trouble sleeping
what I'll do is I'll play
an entire round of golf
on this 18 holes in my head.
Because I remember every hole.
I could draw, I could
draw every hole for you.
That's cool, so.
Almost to the point
of every sand trap.
If you were imprisoned and
they threw you in a hole.
This is how you can.
I play golf in my head.
Cling to reality.
I would shoot
so many great scores in my head.
But one of the things
that this has done for me
is it's given me this incredible desire
to play the course again.
It's been probably 15 years
since I've played the course.
Okay.
And over the past 10 years
since we've been in L.A.,
multiple times I've tried to set up
my dad and my brother
and I playing Keith Hills
and something has always come up.
The last time it was like,
the trip got changed because
of COVID or something.
So I'm looking at the weather,
I'm thinking about the fact
that I just got exposed
by my wife but I'm also thinking,
"You know, maybe I'm immune to it
"and also I'm gonna be
outside the whole day."
So, and I of course I told
my brother and my dad.
I was like, "I still want to play golf.
"Jessie's got COVID, we had
missionary sex last night."
I didn't tell them that but I was like,
"I'm pretty sure I've been exposed."
And they're both like, "We don't care.
"Whatever, we're gonna be playing golf.
"Not a big deal."
Okay.
And the weather's getting bad.
Like it looks like it's
gonna maybe rain us out.
I'm like of course,
of course, of course I'm
gonna get rained out.
I'm gonna get COVID,
I'm gonna not be able to play the course.
You're in a bad head space man.
But the weather gods who may
or may not be just God,
decided to smile upon us
and it did not rain at all.
And I played, I know
no one cares about this
but I'm gonna say it anyway.
Because I care about it.
I played so well.
The thing is is that you know if you know,
playing golf can be so frustrating
but when it's not frustrating
it's almost as good as missionary sex.
And it is, I mean it was just like,
I could not believe how
well I was hitting it.
I was just hitting these drives.
In fact there was a guy who was
out there trying to get his,
he's getting ready to
do a qualifying thing
to become, not a tour pro,
but like a pro shop pro.
Every pro shop has a pro.
Yeah.
A person who is
a professional golfer.
He's not necessarily playing on the tour
but he's a pro golfer.
And he was like, we let him play through
because he was like,
"I got a qualifying round tomorrow
"and I'm kind of getting
in some practice."
He saw my drive and he said, "Nice piece."
Piece.
Nice piece.
We had never heard,
we had never heard a golf
shot referred to as a piece.
I don't like that.
But I'm beginning to do it more often now.
Because a pro, potential pro is doing it.
Anyway, I had an incredible time
and I also was like,
I don't even think I'm
gonna get COVID man.
Can a guy who just recently got COVID
hit the ball like this?
I don't think so.
Or maybe that's the only reason you could.
Yeah, I go to sleep that night
and I wake up.
I wake up in chills, fever, headache,
regret, I take a COVID test.
Of course it's positive.
Of course.
I mean, I mean you didn't really make
a responsible decision but
I'm just gonna go on record
and say that.
Okay what part of it?
What part of it?
The golf part.
Playing outside?
Exposing your dad.
First of all, you know as well as I know,
COVID behaves completely
differently in North Carolina.
Yeah.
They don't think about it
in the same way.
Well you know,
it was their call.
In fact when the California
people are like, hey I
think I might have COVID
they're like, "We don't care."
It's just a completely
different perspective there.
You know and so, neither
one of them got it.
I will say my brother and
my dad did not get COVID.
Okay.
My brother had
already had it.
My dad hasn't had it, maybe he is immune.
Yep and that's the statement
that makes people get it.
That's how I mysticize this thing.
The moment you start saying,
"I haven't gotten it.
"I kind of think I'm not gonna get it."
Yeah, that's where
I was thinking.
That's when you get it.
Well but here's the
really interesting thing.
Now the entire time that
we're in North Carolina,
everything has shifted.
We're like, we were planning
on being in this hotel
for a little bit while Jessie
is working on the house
and then we were going
to drive to the beach
to spend the 4th of July
with her family down at the beach
and then come back to L.A..
And of course now it's like,
well we're COVID buddies.
Gonna be in this hotel room
for who knows how long.
The thing I've failed to
mention up to this point
is the nature of the
hotel we're staying in.
We're staying in a hotel.
For ceilings?
No their ceilings are plenty high
but we're staying in a
hotel on Franklin street
called The Graduate which
you know about The Graduate.
Have I, we stayed there one?
I've stayed at.
I haven't stayed.
I've stayed at The Graduate in Nashville,
The Graduate in Providence, Rhode Island.
It's like a really cool hotel chain
that takes the themes of wherever it is
and incorporates it into a trendy,
sort of hipstery situation.
In this particular case,
it themes it around Carolina basketball.
Ew, gross.
Which is almost as bad as COVID.
So I had COVID but I'm also stuck.
Carolina blue walls.
Oh, just in my room,
there is a, there are side
tables with rams on them.
There are pictures of
Michael Jordan and Dean Smith
that I cannot not look at.
Just outside the room,
there is a giant courtyard inside
that is a literal replica
of the Carolina court
with two basketball goals.
And then the front desk has a scoreboard
with the final score from the
1982 National Championship,
whichever one they won.
This is not the place for you.
And I thought I was gonna be
there for a couple of days.
And I was like, "My
wife's a Carolina grad."
I do, let me just say,
I have matured around this
issue over the past few years.
I think just being in California
where no one cares about
the rivalry and also,
NC State doesn't,
Carolina doesn't really
consider State a rival.
I love that you threw everybody
who's really into this rivalry,
you just threw them all under
the bus as being immature.
No, okay what I'm saying is
to as I have gotten older,
my belief that I, or my willingness
to let NC State's
performance against Carolina
or anyone else determine
my happiness from afar
has seemed to be foolish.
I mean that's more of a statement
about NC State athletics than
it is about your maturity.
But tying your personal wellbeing
to the performance of
a group of 20-year-olds
that you can't control does seem immature.
But listen, I can't help
it, it's in my blood.
I still care about sports,
I'm not gonna stop caring.
But I care a little bit
less than I used to.
So I was able to somewhat enjoy being,
because first of all,
before I knew I had COVID,
I did walk around on
Franklin street a little bit
and I was like,
"This is a cool spot, I gotta admit.
"It's a cool spot.
"This is a cool college
town, it's a cool campus."
Whatever, I just don't like
them for a lot of other reasons.
But once we knew we had COVID,
we did not leave the hotel room.
We told the front desk that we had COVID,
we said we're gonna need
stuff brought to us.
They didn't have room service.
But we're gonna be doing
DoorDash, et cetera
and we need somebody to
bring that to our door.
Knock, walk away.
So we were taking it very seriously.
Stuck in this hotel room.
Let me just say and this is,
probably a pretty good time for you to,
because I'm gonna stop talking about
what my experience was.
I had a great time in Hawaii.
Let's go back to that.
You ended up getting COVID as well.
Not from me.
Yeah it was so strange.
You and I got it almost at the same time
being totally separate.
After all of this time of us avoiding it,
we both got it independently
of one another.
But so did everyone, everyone did.
I got it, my wife got it,
you got it, your wife got it.
Locke ended getting up.
Yep.
Jenna ended up getting it.
Jenna, you got it
independent of both of us.
Yeah.
Everybody.
We spent so much time together.
Everybody I know who
made it until this point
without getting it, got it.
I know very few people that didn't get it.
Christy came, yeah it's like,
you know we got back from Hawaii.
I got back from Aspen and then that week,
my nieces came in from out of town.
First time I was hanging out
with them for three days.
We went to Universal Studios,
took them there for the day and night.
Had a blast.
Next day they flew back.
That night, Christy starts feeling bad
and I think went ahead
and tested positive.
My nieces never ended up getting it
but I think we picked it up.
I mean you know, I'm
guessing it was at Universal.
She started feeling bad
that night, after Universal.
Yeah.
It can't happen
that quickly.
Maybe it was earlier than that.
Yeah I'm pretty sure that's what happened.
She had these flu-like symptoms,
body aches, headache, fever.
Just being totally, just
grounded in the bed you know?
Just couldn't do anything.
My throat was scratchy, never had a fever
but I think it was a couple of days after
that I tested positive.
Around the time when I was
gonna come back to work.
So that's when things started
getting really frustrating
because I.
We had been gone on vacation
kind of a staggered vacation
and then you get COVID
a little bit after me.
Yeah.
You're waiting
to test negative so we
can actually work again.
When you have so much that
piled up and was ready to go,
I really experienced flashbacks
to the beginning of the pandemic
and just remembering how
difficult it was to like,
have so much
that you felt like you needed to do.
But you couldn't, I could do so little.
So you got better before me.
Well, but we haven't talked
about how bad it did get.
Yeah it was like.
For me.
You have this attitude of like,
well I'm fully vaccinated, boosted.
I'm just gonna go ahead and get it.
Let's just get this thing over with.
Because it won't be that
big of a deal anyway.
I mean when Lando got it,
actually before our Hawaii vacation,
he didn't feel great for a day and a half
and then.
He was 12.
He was, it was not a big deal.
For one day.
Well, and.
But yeah it was
freaking tough man.
For a lot of people,
for a lot of people, the
original Omicron wave
which happened around
Christmas was very mild
for everyone I knew who had got it.
But this, I'm pretty sure we both.
All of us probably got BA.4 or BA.5
which is the new variant right?
Yeah.
I would not characterize
this as mild.
I mean obviously I was not anywhere close
to going to the hospital or anything.
But I just haven't gotten sick.
There weren't any breathing issues
with anybody.
In a long time.
But it was more like down
with Christy and with you,
it was like flu symptoms.
Well for me, I had a 103
point something fever
which is like, that's like whoa,
you getting up there, you might need to go
to the emergency room.
I wasn't gonna do that but
that was what my fever was.
Chills were incredible.
It, the headache was really intense
and there was probably a 24,
a 48-hour period in which
I would, in the, at night
time, it would get like that
and then I would kind of
be okay during the day.
I recovered pretty quickly after that.
We spent about five days
in this hotel together.
Anyway, I'll just say that you know,
it's not just a cold.
It might be that for a lot of people
and I hope it is.
Yeah.
For most people but it's not just a cold.
And now it's also,
I mean obviously the thing that from,
since we've learned more about this
is the worrisome thing is this long COVID
which is affecting a reasonably
high percentage of people
who are having these symptoms.
Some debilitating symptoms
for an extended period of time.
That's why this, "It's just
a cold, forget about it.
"It's just at worst a flu."
Is just a bull, ignorant way
to think about this thing
because it's just not consistent
with the truth about this
which is ooh, this thing is
gonna keep infecting people
and we don't know about
these longterm symptoms
and this is not a small deal.
We can't, oh it's just
gonna become endemic
and it's gonna be fine.
Hopefully that will happen eventually
but both of us have been talking about,
and I was kind of, I said,
"Is this in my head?"
But over the past few weeks,
it has become an inescapable fact that I,
something happened to my brain.
I got the COVID brain.
Forgetting very simple
things that I obviously knew.
Thinking about something,
losing my train of thought
in the middle of something.
Hopefully these are temporary
symptoms that will go away.
But I'm gonna tell you right now,
it's a real thing and
it's a big fricking deal
like on a global scale
that we will be figuring
out and reckoning with.
Think the globe's gonna
get a little dumber?
If we all get equally dumber,
then maybe it's not that bad.
But it'll be more difficult to
solve problems as a species.
Now I don't know what it
says about me but I've had,
I hadn't had the fidelity
of being able to ascertain
whether my brain fog
is just a way of life or if it's,
a little bit.
I mean I don't know man.
I just think that.
Because I have name fright.
I can't remember people's names.
We were talking about my therapy
with my family the other
day and Lily was like,
"What's your therapist's name?"
And I was like, I got this
deer in the headlights look
and I couldn't remember
my own therapist's name.
I had to look
it up on my phone.
That kind of stuff
has been happening to me and I'm like,
it was sudden and it was totally tied
to that experience and again,
I'm trying to not to.
Do you know his name by the way because?
I still can't remember it.
Your original therapist?
No, I remember his name.
Yeah.
My new therapist.
No, I don't.
I'm joking.
I do remember his name now.
You want me to say it?
Don't say it.
So anyway, I mean not to
get on the soapbox there
but yeah, it's like you know.
It ain't over.
Yeah I felt.
I do feel
that having gotten it and
it not being fun at all
and not a breeze at all.
I do feel differently about it.
And also it's just like, you know,
I don't want people to be
going around super scared
and I understand all the
negative consequences
to living a life of fear
and I don't want to do that
and I haven't been doing that.
But it just kind of
sucks that the reality is
we can't just move on
like everything's normal.
That's why we still take
these precautions at Mythical.
We get tested every week
and people wear masks
and it's not gonna
completely protect you but.
And I think when you.
You gotta do something.
When you do get it, just
giving yourself permission
to recover.
Give yourself time.
You know?
Instead of trying to push
through which they're actually.
I think that's good
advice, that's safe advice.
I think I'll leave it at that.
It's sound advice
because trying to push through physically
or even mentally can
prolong your recovery.
Okay, so we eventually
get to a place where we,
now we're still testing positive.
But Jessie's family are like,
"Y'all come down to the daggone beach."
And we're like, well we're gonna,
of course we're not gonna get close to you
and we're wear masks the whole time.
And of course again, North
Carolina, they're like,
"Okay, whatever you want to do.
"We don't care."
So we go down there and I didn't,
thankfully I didn't have the
fatigue and so I was able.
I kind of felt like, I'm kind of back.
Fatigue was a big part of it for me.
So thankfully I didn't.
Head cold, congestion
and fatigue.
Those were my big things.
So we were kind of staying
away from everybody
as well as we possibly could.
Thankfully none of them
ended up getting it.
But you know, on July.
So on, we had July 4th, little
celebration, get together.
And then July 5th was
the day that I announced
the James and the Shame project.
I was like "Hey, this is
something I've been working on.
"Here's a little Instagram post."
So on July 4th during the day,
Jessie and I were like,
"Hey we haven't really
been outside to take a walk
"on the beach."
Because we've been trying
to really take it easy
and fully recover
but we both felt like we
could go out on the beach
and take a walk.
And so we go out.
I'm kind of feeling like
you walked together this time.
Yeah we're walking side by side,
not in a 50-yard line.
Because things were great with us.
And we are walking down the
beach and literally the first.
It's so, I love the North Carolina coast.
I mean I'm just gonna be honest with you.
When you go in July and
you get in that water.
Oh yeah.
You just start thinking,
"Man this is better."
I'm sorry, the beach is better here.
The beach is better
than California beaches.
Let's just be honest.
It may not be as pretty.
Bath water.
Or as pristine because it
doesn't have the mountains
and the cliffs and stuff.
But there's nobody there.
When families,
you start feeling like
you might be too close
to another family when
they're 100 feet away.
You know what I'm saying?
There's just so much room.
Hey, you don't have
to tell me.
I talk to my dad every week.
Yeah, right.
So, but the first little
family group that we come to
recognizes me.
"Oh, Rhett.
"Hey, can we get a picture?"
And I said, "Yeah I do
want to let you know."
I didn't have my mask on
because I'm walking outside and I'm like,
"I'm recovering from COVID
"so I don't want you to get too close."
Okay.
I was like, I didn't want to be like,
"Don't get too close to me."
Without telling them
and I didn't want to
let them get close to me
because I'm trying to be respectful.
So we ended up getting a picture
and this guy and this
girl were kind of on.
I tell some fans I have herpes sometimes.
Yeah, just don't touch my lips.
There's, there are
probably like two people.
It's a weird picture, I'm sure.
I didn't see it but I'm
sure it's a weird picture.
Probably taken in landscape
given the fact that
they're this far from me.
It's like you're photo bombing their
photo.
I thought nothing of it.
You know, it was a
slightly weird interaction
'cause I'm like, "Don't touch me.
"Don't get close to me 'cause
I'm recovering from COVID."
And then the reason I said that,
the next day I share on Instagram
about James and the Shame
because I got this comment
on my Instagram post.
Not gonna say who it's from.
"I actually met this due
on the beach yesterday
"and he seemed annoyed
that I recognized him.
"Don't meet your heroes I guess."
Hah.
Seemed annoyed.
Dude, I told you
that I was recovering from COVID.
Hah.
I mean I almost responded
to this comment but then I just like,
I'm gonna wait and we're
gonna talk about COVID
on the podcast.
But I told you that I had
COVID and that's why I didn't,
you think I made that up?
Let me read it.
Not so I can say the
person's name out loud
but I'm going to.
You don't have to say the
person's name out loud.
Actually met this dude.
And also.
So doesn't sound like a fan.
Weird.
It had,
it had to have been.
It was the only person I met
on the beach the day before.
So he wasn't like a significant other
of a fan?
He was the one
who said Rhett.
Oh.
So, anyway.
Thanks for this.
Thanks a lot for that.
Dude.
Should've just given him COVID.
Don't meet your heroes,
they might have COVID
and tell you to not get close to them.
Don't be so annoyed about it.
The assholes, what?
Don't be so annoyed.
Him, he shouldn't be so annoyed about it.
Is that what you mean?
No, you man.
Why are you so annoyed?
Well you know it's like, because.
I actually had a
conversation with this dude
about what you're commenting about.
He seemed annoyed then too.
Well I think the reason that
it gets on my nerves so much.
I know why it gets on your nerves.
No it's because, like all it takes
is one little story like
that for people to be like,
"Oh you know that guy's
actually an asshole in person."
And so I'm, I don't just,
I'm not just nice to people
because I have a reputation to maintain.
I'm nice to people because
I am nice to people
and I also appreciate if
people want to come up
and if they're fans of the show,
I really appreciate that.
That day on the four plane day
where I'm in these airports
and I'm rushing around
wondering if I'm gonna get,
lots of people came up to me that day.
And I was like, "I'm
having a really shitty day
"but I'm not going to let them know it."
You know what I'm saying?
So I was like, put on a smile
and had a good interaction.
I just thought that was especially.
That's a tough one man.
You know.
Par for the course with
the life you're living now.
But it was kind of sort of proper way
to wrap up the vacation.
Right.
Because that was the kind of
thing that, it just characterizes
the whole experience.
But I will say that coming back,
fully recovering except for some brain fog
and some forgetfulness,
whatever is happening.
And then you know,
it's really nice when
you can get back home
and be happy A, to be in
your own home and be like,
"I really like the home that we have.
"I like the home that we have built."
Yeah.
Not just the home itself.
The house itself.
I love my toilet.
But the people in my home.
And then to have a job that
you want to come back to.
There's a lot,
there is a lot to be thankful for.
When your vacation sucks, yeah.
Well it does put that into perspective
because I think that there's you know,
plenty of people who are like,
"Man I hate my job.
"All I do is look forward to a vacation
"and then when I'm on vacation
"all I do is dread the fact
"that I'm gonna have to go back to work."
It's nice to be like,
"You know I'm ready, I'm
ready to get back at it."
It has been tough coming back though
after everything being
delayed because of our,
especially me being sick.
It delayed our whole production schedule.
It's been tough to try to,
because we've had to cram everything in.
It's like jumping into the deep end.
Yeah.
When you're not on vacation.
Everything has been stacked on itself.
Which is why we're going
on another vacation.
We're going on a long weekend vacation.
We're about to go back to Colorado.
We're going to meet our college friends.
Yeah I think.
And we're gonna go white water rafting.
Yeah, if we'd survived,
this'll make another great podcast.
Yeah if is is the last podcast
just 'cause, I don't know.
Either one of our
college friends killed us
or something bad happened
white water rafting.
Well I have said on our group thread
that this is the perfect
setup for a horror movie
or a thriller.
Yeah.
Because it's like,
you get together with your college friends
that you haven't really hung
out with in this fashion
in 20 year.
When any of my boys.
Everybody's having a great time.
Start getting topless,
then because when you something bad
is gonna happen.
Somebody's gonna die.
Yep.
So yeah we might have
an incredible story to tell next time.
All right, but in the
meantime you got a rec.
Yeah go whale watching.
I'd never thought I wanted
to go whale watching
because yeah just think about
everything but seeing a whale
assuming that you won't see one.
But man, even in the worst vacation ever,
you saw all those whales.
Now I've set the standard,
I saw two blue whales
and they did the tail thing.
Yeah yeah.
Go whale watching huh?
So I can't guarantee
that you'll have to kind of experience
but I will say you should dress warmly,
definitely take anti-nausea medicine.
I took Dramamine.
Still got a little, I started to feel
a little bit seasick on the way out.
But I was like, I'm just
gonna breathe deeply
and get through this
and I did, it was fine.
All right, solid rec.
That would be
my only concern for the Neal family.
There might be some sickness
that you might encounter.
Maybe I'll see one when
I'm going scuba diving.
Yeah.
That would be crazy.
That would be awesome,
yeah go whale watching.
All right, we'll speak at you next week.
#EarBiscuits and of course,
you can always call and let us know
what your reaction is to listening
to the latest episode.
1877.
888.
What is it?
Is it 888, yeah.
1-888-EARPOD1.
COVID brain.
Hey Rhett and Link,
this is Jake from Albuquerque,
just listening to Link recall
his family vacation in Maui
and it was very fitting
because I was there
around this time last year
where I proposed to my girlfriend
at the top of Haleakala
and now we are set to be married
and we're actually flying
out to Greece this week
for that marriage.
So I don't know, Link if you're
just following me around,
maybe you need to go to Greece next year.
I can tell you all about
that trip when I get back.
Thanks for all the content
that you put out there.
Everything's great, love
"Dispatches From Myrtle Beach".
Can't wait to recognize your dad.
Hi Rhett and Link, it's Hayley.
I just wanted to come on and
say that I am just so excited
for Rhett's solo music project.
I am just so excited that you guys
are being able to do separate things.
You know I also love
Link's podcast with his dad
and it's just been awesome
to see you guys branch out
and do separate things
but also stay together
and do your funny stuff.
Hey Rhett and Link,
so I have a friend named Kefir,
that is not why I'm calling.
I'm calling because I
have a bottle of kefir
in front of me for the very first time.
Which I have just tried
and it was all because of you
because I'd never heard
of this in my entire life.
First opinions, I got the blueberry.
I think it tastes pretty good.
It just reminds me really
of liquified yogurt
which is fine and I'll let you know
if it starts making me happy.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.